if you didn't think you could love keanu
reeves more
wait until you hear academy award winner
octavia spencer's
sweet story about the star throughout
his career reeves has earned a
reputation for being one of the nicest
guys in the film industry
whether he's quietly giving up his seat
on the subway or helping fellow
passengers on a flight forced to make an
emergency landing ahead of its final
destination
as it turns out reeves who has seen a
recent career resurgence thanks to
intense action movies like the john wick
franchise
as well as charming cameos and romantic
comedies like
always be my maybe is also super nice to
fellow actors in need
no matter the situation during a
socially distanced interview on the
graham norton show
the host who is well known for drawing
incredible stories out of his guests
asked the hidden figure star to tell her
kiana reeves story
and spencer happily obliged as spencer
told norton
her reeves experience was quite early in
her career
when spencer was headed to grab a script
for an audition
she was dressed pretty informally which
she revealed to norton years after the
fact
it was about 25 years ago the matrix had
just come out
was on my way to pick up a script to
read for an audition
though this story seems innocuous at
first it definitely gets
weirder from there as spencer revealed
to norton she was running errands while
pretty dressed down
wearing a worn see-through t-shirt
sweatpants and no underwear
and her outfit's not the only thing that
wasn't looking totally presentable that
day
my car hadn't been washed because i
always parked underneath the tree
and there was bird crap all over the
back of it
according to spencer her car
unexpectedly broke down in what she
described as a posh area of beverly
hills
leaving her stranded in the street with
cars honking all around her
making matters worse people at an
outdoor cafe could see the scene
unfolding but no one helped her
that is until keanu hi i'm keanu reeves
according to spencer help arrived
suddenly in the form of a striking man
and sunglasses and a motorcycle helmet
whom she immediately could tell was
keanu reeves in the flesh
while she was quote freaking out about
the celebrity encounter
superstar reeves humbly offered his
assistance
i thought he was going to get into the
car i got behind the car to push
he said no i'm going to push you out of
the street you get in
pushing the car out of the street keanu
didn't just help a stranger out
he also set an example just by being
himself
according to spencer when people saw it
was keanu reeves helping me
everybody came down to help now i know
what it feels like to be completely
starstruck
while octavia spencer may have been
having a bad day when she first met
keanu reeves
the past 25 years have been plenty kind
to both of them
in the years since their first encounter
both of them have established themselves
as two of hollywood's biggest
stars after playing a series of small
roles in both film and television
spencer's biggest breakthrough came in
2011 with the help
a story which chronicles the lives of
black maids in the south
in the heavily segregated era of the
1960s
ultimately spencer won an academy award
for best supporting actress for her role
and in the years since she's appeared in
other high-profile projects like ma
hidden figures get on up and more
meanwhile reeves who rose to fame thanks
to films like point break
matrix and bill and ted's excellent
adventure in the 1990s
has experienced a renaissance in recent
years blowing audiences away with his
high octane stunts in the john wick
films
he also recently wrapped filming on the
long-awaited fourth matrix film
where he'll reprise his leading role as
neo and has promised audiences that the
sequel
will be well worth the wait whether
reeves is playing a wronged hitman
or spoofing his own self-image on screen
you can't help but root for it which
makes it all the more rewarding when you
hear about this humble star taking time
out of his day to do a good deed for a
stranger
it's also a lucky circumstance that
spencer's career took off
or we might never have heard this story
at all reeves
two huge upcoming sequels the matrix iv
and john wick chapter four
are currently scheduled for release in
december 2021
and may 2022 respectively you can see
spencer in the witches
which is now streaming exclusively on
hbo max
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one